und verbunden
ja liebe Ursula herzlich willkommen
nochmal in Meseberg der Ort ist der ja
aus vielen früheren Begegnungen gut
vertraut und das war dann ja auch die
Grundlage für ein sehr gutes sehr
vertrauensvolles und sehr konstruktives
Gespräch dass wir hier miteinander
hatten zum Auftakt unser
Kabinettsklausur haben wir darüber
gesprochen wie wir unsere europäische
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit langfristig sichern
können wie wir dafür Sorge tragen können
dass Europa seine Rolle wahrnehmen kann
als souveränes Europa als souveräner
Europäische Union als geopolitischer
Akteur und die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
gehört zentrale dazu natürlich gilt das
gleichermaßen für unser Land mitten in
Europa und wir sind sehr aufeinander
bezogen richtigerweise denn unsere
Zukunft kann nur gemeinsam gewonnen
werden können deshalb ist es gut dass
die
Präsidentin der Europäischen Kommission
hier als Gesprächspartnerin zu uns
gekommen ist und wir das jetzt alles
haben tief und intensiv miteinander
diskutieren können es gibt viele Fragen
die uns gegenwärtig umtreiben
selbstverständlich ist die wichtigste
Frage wie kriegen wir das hin den
Menschen gemachten Klimawandel
aufzuhalten das ist unsere Perspektive
damit sind viele Umbrüche verbunden und
deshalb ist es ganz wichtig dass in
Europa viele der Investitionen
stattfinden die notwendig sind damit wir
die Wirtschaft der Zukunft auch in
Europa sich stark entwickeln sehen
da freut uns was uns selber möglich ist
da gehört aber auch dazu dass wir alles
tun damit wir im globalen Wettbewerb
bestehen können und deshalb haben wir
uns natürlich auch sehr ausführlich
auseinandergesetzt mit den Konsequenzen
etwa des Inflation reduction Acts und
der Dinge die damit zusammenhängt für
uns ist auch wichtig dass wir an das
anknüpfen was uns jetzt im letzten Jahr
gelungen ist wer hätte gedacht dass nach
dem juristischen Angriff und nach der
massiven Reduzierung russischer
Energielieferung nach Europa ist uns
gelingt unsere Wirtschaft zu
stabilisieren und gemeinsam durch diese
Situation zu kommen ohne eine
Energiekrise erlebt zu haben wenn mit
Preisen zu kämpfen gehabt die
mittlerweile wieder sinken aber das
genau das geschehen ist es eine
gemeinsame Leistung gewesen jetzt geht
es darum eben die nächste Transformation
Zustande zu kriegen und neben der ganz
wichtigen Frage wie kriegen wir das hin
die Technologien zu entwickeln die wir
zum Aufhalten des Menschen gemacht zum
Klimawandels brauchen geht es eben auch
darum wie wir dabei sind wenn es um
Digitalisierung um künstliche
Intelligenz geht all die Entscheidung
die für die Zukunft wichtig sind das
haben wir sehr intensiv und vielerlei
Hinsichten getan und dabei nicht
vergessen dass in Mittelpunkt all der
Aktivitäten die wir vorzunehmen haben
auch der Mensch steht das heißt in
diesem Fall die Frauen und Männer die in
unserem Land arbeiten das hat mir zu tun
mit der Verbesserung der
Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten in Europa
für junge für ältere für Frauen und
Männer aber es geht eben auch darum dass
wir die Möglichkeiten der Fachkräfte
Migration als Europäische Union gut
nutzen und auch das haben wir vertieft
und intensiv diskutiert letzte Bemerkung
natürlich können wir nicht reden ohne
auch ein Blick zu werfen auf den
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
dass wir hier zusammen stehen dass wir
eigentlich geblieben sind das hat
Russland das hat der russische Präsident
sicher niemals erwartet aber unsere
Bereitschaft das auch weiter zu tun und
so lange wie es notwendig ist die
Grundlage dafür dass wir
der Ukraine den Weg in die Europäische
Union weiter ermöglichen können aber
dass wir sie vor allem dabei
unterstützen staatliche Integrität
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit ja
die Freiheit zu verteidigen nochmals
vielen Dank fürs Kommen das war eine
gute
Gespräche hier im Brandenburg und ein
guter Ort
ja vielen Dank ich möchte mich auch
bedanken für die Einladung wieder mal
nach Meseberg zu kommen das ist schön
wieder hier zu sein ich möchte auch
danken für die sehr konstruktiven
intensiven Gespräche die wir geführt
haben in der Tat das alles findet statt
vor dem Hintergrund des russischen
Kriegs in der Ukraine und wenn man
zurückblickt heute ein Jahr nach
Kriegsbeginn steht fest dass Präsident
Putin mit seinen elementaren Zielen die
er hatte zu Beginn dieses Krieges
gescheitert ist er wollte die
ukrainische Regierung durch eine pro
russische ersetzen er ist am Widerstand
der Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
gescheitert er wollte die Pro
europäische Haltung der Ukraine brechen
und in der Tat er hat das Gegenteil
erreicht heute ist die Ukraine
beitrittskandidatin auf dem Weg in die
Europäische Union
und
wie es gerade eben gesagt wurde
Präsident Putin hat damit gerechnet die
Einigkeit in der Europäischen Union über
unsere damalige Abhängigkeit von
russischen fossilen Brennstoffen brechen
zu können das Gegenteil ist eingetreten
Europas Abhängigkeit von russischen Öle
und Gast ist heute Geschichte
russland hat seine gastexporte nach
Europa innerhalb von acht Monaten um 80%
reduziert zurückgefahren und es ist uns
gelungen gemeinsam das durch harte
Arbeit zu kompensieren sicherlich hat
geholfen dass gute Freunde wie die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und
Norwegen uns unterstützt haben über
Flüssiggas und pipelinegas
beachtenswert ist aber auch dass die
Europäerinnen und Europäer ihren Beitrag
geleistet haben in dem 20% des
Energiekonsums eingespart worden ist im
letzten Jahr
und wir haben massiv in die erneuerbaren
Energien investiert die Bilanz kann sich
sehen lassen 2022 wurde in Europa zum
ersten Mal mehr Strom aus Wind und Sonne
produziert als aus Gas und es ist uns
gelungen in der Bilanz dass die MS
CO2-Emissionen nicht angestiegen sind
nicht stagniert haben sondern um 2,5%
gesunken sind dennoch und das war auch
Gegenstand unserer Diskussionen sind
Energiekosten für Unternehmen im
Vergleich zu anderen Regionen dieser
Welt relativ hoch und wir müssen
gemeinsam unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
verbessern
wir müssen den Fokus darauf legen dass
wir auch in Zukunft die führende Region
sein werden bei den sauberen
Technologien Technologien wir müssen die
Rahmenbedingungen für cleantec
verbessern Klinik ist heute der die am
schnellsten wachsende Industriebranche
und investitionssektor in Europa wir
sind bei vielen Technologien sauberen
Technologien Weltmarktführer wenn man
sich einfach die Brennstoffzellen
anschaut wenn man sich die
Wasserstoffwirtschaft anschaut wenn man
sich das Thema Windturbinen anschaut
aber jetzt ist entscheidend dass wir
diesen Vorsprung auch halten
und das alles diskutieren wir vor der
Tatsache dass die USA ihren Inflation
reduction Act vorgelegt haben der auf
der einen Seite massive
Steuererleichterung für den Clean
textsektor bringt und zum Teil auch sehr
klar ein by American Logik unterliegt
erstmal im Grundsatz muss man sagen
diese Investitionen in den kliniksektor
in den USA sind gut weil sie gut für die
Bekämpfung des Klimawandels sind aber
sie bereiten uns auch zum Teil
Schwierigkeiten deshalb haben wir die
Antworten diskutiert die wir darauf
geben können erstens Verhandlungen mit
den USA bei der Auslegung des Gesetzes
sind wichtig zweitens eigene
Investitionen und drittens schnellere
Verfahren
zu den Verhandlungen mit den USA ist
entscheidend dass wir unsere
Automobilindustrie auch den Zugang zu
den Steuerprivilegien in den USA
verschaffen das ist gelungen in einem
ersten Schritt wenn wir uns das Thema
Elektroautos anschauen wir müssen noch
arbeiten mit den USA zum Thema Batterie
und Batterie Komponenten
zweiter Punkt der wichtig ist
wenn wir uns das amerikanische Gesetz
anschauen mit den Steuererleichterungen
dann ist es wichtig dass wir ähnlich in
der Lage sind hier auch in unsere
cleantec-industrie zu investieren das
geht einerseits über die Beihilfe
aber es geht andererseits und das ist
die andere Seite der Medaille auch über
europäische Mittel die bisher nicht
genutzt worden sind das ist die zweite
Komponente die wir in 14 Tagen in einem
gesetzesakt vorschlagen werden
und ich habe hier in Meseberg dann auch
ein Ausblick darauf gegeben wie das
weitere größere Paket für die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit aussehen wird dass
wir übernächste Woche vorstellen das
wird eine Mitteilung der Kommission sein
da geht's darum Hürden im Binnenmarkt
abzubauen es geht darum dass wir die
industrielle Basis in Europa stärken das
heißt wir brauchen mehr Innovationen um
klimafreundliches Wirtschaften
tatsächlich auch dann in die Tat
umsetzen zu können große Komponente wird
das Thema Fachkräftemangel spielen eine
große Rolle wird das Thema
Fachkräftemangel spielen wo wir deutlich
den wir deutlich stärker angehen müssen
der Fachkräftemangel ist eine unserer
potentiell stärksten Wachstumsbremsen
und schlussendlich haben wir auch
darüber diskutiert wie Europa bewusst
mehr auf Handel setzen kann wir haben
vor kurzem Abkommen mit Chile und
Neuseeland abgeschlossen und meine
Kommission arbeitet derzeit an
Abschlüssen mit Australien Mexiko und
Mercosur
wir müssen viel tun aber wir haben auch
viel zu bieten das sollten wir nie
vergessen wir haben den größten
Binnenmarkt der Welt wir haben
exzellente Unternehmen die globale
Technologieführer sind wir haben ein
fachkräfterreservoir das seinesgleichen
weltweit sucht also geht es darum mit
dem was wir besprochen haben unsere
Stärken zu stärken vielen Dank
Frau von der Leyen ich hätte ganz gerne
eine Frage zu einem Thema was jetzt
nicht erwähnt haben es gibt ja in der
Bundesregierung Streit über das Ende des
verbrennermotors was auch Auswirkungen
auf die europäische Ebene hat ich hätte
ganz gerne gewusst ob die EU-Kommission
einen neuen Vorschlag vorlegen wird der
vielleicht dazu führt dass man dieses
Probleme beseitigen kann wenn ja wann
ist es soweit und sie hatten eben
erwähnt Handelsabkommen mit Australien
Mexiko Merkur was ist denn mit dem
Handelsabkommen mit Indien ist das auch
in greifbarer Nähe und der Bundeskanzler
da die kommissionspräsidentin gerade
neben ihm steht und Herr März sich für
eine zweite Amtszeit ausgesprochen hätte
hatte ich hätte von ihnen ganz gerne
gewusst ob sie auch für eine zweite
Amtszeit der Kommissionspräsident sind
danke
die
Freihandelsabkommen die ich erwähnt habe
sind diejenigen wo wir daran arbeiten
sie noch in diesem Mandat abzuschließen
also bis Ende des Jahres in der Tat wir
arbeiten an einem Freihandelsabkommen
mit Indien und Indonesien das wird aber
nicht innerhalb dieses Jahres möglich
sein das braucht mehr Zeit aber die
Offenheit ist da und das ist eine
deutliche Veränderung gegenüber den
Jahren den vorherigen Jahren die
Offenheit Indiens ist damit uns auch ein
Freihandelsabkommen abzuschließen
das
zweite Thema dass Sie angesprochen haben
wurde heute auch kurz angesprochen wir
sind dort in einem konstruktiven Dialog
ich will nur mal sehr deutlich
klarstellen volle Unterstützung für das
Prinzip der technologieoffenheit das ist
wichtig aber das muss auch immer in
Balance mit unseren klimapolitischen
Zielen stehen über die wir uns auch alle
geeinigt haben und das ist genau das
Gleichgewicht was wir erarbeiten müssen
daran arbeiten wir noch aber die
Diskussion ist sehr gut und konstruktiv
gewesen
ja ich kann das auch nur bestätigen da
sind konstruktive Diskussionen im Gange
übrigens haben wir sowohl Indonesien als
auch Indien jetzt hier vertieft auch
besprochen in unserem längeren Gespräch
das sind schon Freihandelsabkommen die
wir auch miteinander vorantreiben wollen
und die natürlich eine große Bedeutung
haben auch in der gopolitischen
Perspektive ansonsten arbeiten wir hier
sehr freundschaftlich zusammen ich weiß
nicht genau was die für Europa
kandidierenden Parteien sich so
vorstellen aber ich glaube die halten
weiter am Spitzenkandidaten Prinzip fest
[Musik]
ich wollte einmal fragen nach der nach
dem was sie sich was sie gesagt haben
sie wollen ja Ruhe
reinbringen in die Gespräche und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen ins
Kabinett sehen Sie denn dass sie morgen
zu irgendwelchen Abschlüssen kommen
werden bezüglich planungsbeschleunigung
oder anderen streithemen innerhalb der
Koalition und Frau von alleine ich
wollte auch noch mal fragen es gibt ja
in Deutschland viele streith Themen wo
es gerade um Klimaschutz geht und wo ist
wo genau dieser dieser Punkt so stark
gemacht wird wie schaut denn die
EU-Kommission auf solche Sachen wie Öl
heizungsverbote und genau diese
Diskussion
zunächst mal ist es so dass wir hier
eine Klausur haben bei der wir ein paar
Themen verhandeln miteinander und uns
dafür die Zeit nehmen die nicht so jeden
Tag auf der Tagesordnung stehen das war
auch der Grund warum wir uns sehr
gefreut haben dass wir hier mit Ursula
von der Leyen sprechen können und die
kommissionspräsidentin hat mit uns
wirklich ein gutes langes Gespräch über
Europa die Perspektiven geführt will
jetzt noch mal für mich sagen Europa ist
für uns in Deutschland die wichtigste
nationale Frage und deshalb ist der
Fortschritt in Europa auch ein Anliegen
dass wir als Regierung und als Land sehr
verfolgen was die
Situationen betrifft
unsere Arbeit gibt es für mich einen
ganz entscheidenden Punkt zu sagen
nämlich wir haben Deutschland gemeinsam
in einer angesichts einer ganz großen
Herausforderung die mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine verbunden
ist sicher durch eine große Krise
geführt das merkt sich macht sich
vielleicht nicht für jeden so bemerkbar
weil sie ausgeblieben ist aber sie war
vor uns wir haben es geschafft dass es
warm ist wir haben nicht draußen aber
hier drin wir haben geschafft dass die
Energieversorgung Deutschlands
gewährleistet ist die Preise sinken
sogar wieder wir haben für den sozialen
Zusammenhalt gesorgt und die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger Unternehmen entlastet so dass
es auch nicht zu einer Wirtschaftskrise
gekommen ist alles das was manche uns im
letzten Jahr vorhergesagt haben und
unserem Land das ist nicht eingetreten
und das ist die Leistung auf die wir
jetzt aufbauen wir haben viel vor um
unser Land in die Zukunft zu führen das
sind ist mit vielen Veränderungen
verbunden und deshalb ist es auch völlig
normal dass über diese vielen Schritte
die dazugehören sehr intensiv diskutiert
wird weil es ja einfach ist nicht zu tun
und die Augen vor den Herausforderungen
der Zukunft zu verschließen
herausfordernder ist dafür zu sorgen
dass man diesen Aufgaben gerecht wird
und das ist das was wir uns vorgenommen
haben wir wollen es schaffen dass
Deutschland
zehn Jahren 80 Prozent seines Stroms aus
erneuerbaren Energien bezieht und damit
voranschreitet auch in Europa wir wollen
2045 klimaneutral wirtschaften wir
wollen sicherstellen dass eine ganz
große neue Wachstumsphase unser Land
begleitet in den nächsten Jahren die
notwendig ist um diese Transformationen
genauso bei modernen Technologien die
etwa mit der Digitalisierung verbunden
sind auch tatsächlich zu ermöglichen und
wir sind sicher dass wir das schaffen
insofern ist das wirklich eine Regierung
die anpackt und nicht die und nicht weg
guckt vor den Herausforderungen der
Zukunft aber wir werden auch diese Sache
für unser Land so einrichten das ist gut
funktioniert wie es uns gelungen ist
gleich im ersten Jahr unsere Tätigkeit
eine große Krise zu meistern die uns
gedroht hätte wenn wir das nicht
entschlossen angepackt hätten was auf
uns zugekommen ist
zu der Ihrer Frage Klimaschutz
wir haben vor ein bisschen mehr als drei
Jahren mit dem European green Deal
angefangen da haben wir sozusagen unsere
Ziele weit gesteckt wir haben dann ein
Klimaschutzgesetz auf den Weg gebracht
dass alle 27 Mitgliedstaaten
unterschrieben haben den wir
verpflichtet sind mit der
Klimaneutralität 2050 und -55%
2030 jetzt haben wir mit Fit for fifty
five sozusagen einen Fahrplan auf den
Weg gebracht mit einzelnen Elementen und
innerhalb dieses Rahmens deshalb
beschreibe ich Ihnen innerhalb dieses
Rahmens haben die verschiedenen
Mitgliedstaaten müssen sie ihren Beitrag
leisten da gibt's verschiedene
Herangehensweise der unterschiedlichen
Mitgliedstaaten für uns als Europäische
Kommission ist vor allen Dingen
entscheidend das Ergebnis dass das
Ergebnis des Beitrages der
Mitgliedstaaten
CO2-Emissionen zu senken stimmt und
daran wird dann eben auch beurteilt wie
die einzelnen aktiv itäten sind
vom Spiegel guten Abend Herr
Bundeskanzler ich will noch einmal
nachhaken es gibt ja bei der Frage das
von
ja hier bin ich es gibt ja bei der
Bewertung dieses Fortschritts den Sie
angesprochen haben ganz unterschiedliche
Ansätze und auch ein Dissens über das
wie ich möchte noch einmal ganz konkret
nachfragen wie sie das Verhalten ihres
Koalitionspartners der FDP bewerten die
ja durch ihren Verkehrsminister
vergangene Woche gedroht hat diesen
Kompromiss der ja bereits weit gediehen
war aufzukündigen und an die Frau
kommissionspräsidentin die Frage was
denn der Zeitraum oder der Zeitrahmen
für eine Einigung in dieser Frage beim
Verbrenner sein könnte
auch vor dem Hintergrund dass ja die
ganzen Automobilhersteller auch
Planungssicherheit brauchen um die von
Ihnen genannten Ziele zu erreichen danke
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage das ist mir
wichtig einmal vorweg zu sagen Volker
Wissing ist ein sehr sehr guter
Verkehrsminister und der wird Spuren in
Deutschland hinterlassen weil er viele
Probleme die liegengeblieben sind in den
letzten Jahren anpackt dazu zählt zum
Beispiel dafür zu sorgen dass es in
Deutschland tatsächlich und nicht nur in
Sonntagsreden 2030 15 Millionen
elektrische Fahrzeuge gibt dazu zählt
dafür Sorge zu tragen dass Tempo
entsteht bei dem Ausbau der Lade
Infrastruktur und natürlich auch die
vielen Herausforderungen anzupacken die
wir jetzt vor uns haben weil wir unser
Bahnnetz verbessern müssen weil wir es
elektrifizieren und digitalisieren
müssen weil wir weiter dafür Sorge
tragen müssen dass wir vorankommen bei
einem gut fließenden Verkehr auch auf
unseren Straßen und insofern hat er
wirklich große Aufgaben vor sich wir
sind uns in dieser Frage einig und
deshalb geht das was wir gegenwärtig mit
der Europäischen Kommission diskutieren
ja nicht um die konkreten Inhalte der
gefundenen Regelung sondern darum wie
etwas worüber wir uns auch in der
Regierung einig sind und auch mit der
Kommission realisiert werden kann
nämlich was ist mit der Perspektive von
Fahrzeugen die sich ausschließlich auf
e-views beziehen nach
2435 es geht also gar nicht um dezente
Fragen sondern die Frage wie geht's und
das ist eine so lösbare Aufgabe dass wir
alle ganz zuversichtlich sind nicht nur
was die Bundesregierung betrifft sondern
auch was unsere Gespräche mit der
Kommission betrifft
dahin zu
ügen Behandlung weiß man erst das
Verhandlung erfolgreich abgeschlossen
sind wenn sie erfolgreich abgeschlossen
sind eigentlich so schnell wie möglich
denn sie haben schon zurecht gesagt es
geht auch um Planungssicherheit für die
Automobilindustrie
[Musik]
von Politiker eine Frage an Sie beide
haben Sie konkrete Beweise von US-Seite
erhalten dass China Waffenlieferungen in
Russland bewegt und würden Sie in solch
einem Fall Sanktion gegen China
befürworten
wir sind uns alle einig dass es keine
Waffenlieferung geben darf und die
chinesische Regierung hat ja bekundet
auch keine zu liefern
das fordern wir ein und das beobachten
wir
bisher haben wir keine Beweise dafür
aber man muss jeden Tag das Beobachten
und in der Tat
die zweite Teil Ihrer Frage ist eine
hypothetische Frage die erst beantwortet
werden kann wenn sie Realität und
Tatsache würde
danke schön
ja meine Damen und Herren da hatten wir
die eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von
der Leyen und dem Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz auf Schloss Meseberg nach einer
Befassung mit dem gesamten Kabinett mit
ein paar Eindrücken keine konkreten
Beschlüssen aber trotzdem manchmal muss
man noch ein bisschen zwischen den
Zeilen hören deswegen freue ich mich das
weiterhin bei uns ist Professor Volker
Kronenberg Politikwissenschaftler
Universität Bonn also durchaus
bemerkenswert ein Besuch von Frau von
der Leyen bei dieser Klausur
nicht historisch aber doch eben
sozusagen ein wichtiger Punkt und
nochmal zu zeigen ihr seid wichtig für
Europa und da muss auch was passieren
dass ihr auch steht in wichtigen Fragen
in diesen konkreten Fragen die die
Kollegen gestellt haben nach dem
Verbrenner aus sind beide eher
blumig geblieben
trotzdem
ist ja nicht unwichtig für sie dorthin
zu gehen denn es geht ja auch um die
Frage wer wäre der nächste
Kommissionspräsident nach den
Europawahlen das ist noch gar nicht
ausgemacht
da hat sich der Bundeskanzler natürlich
geschickt aus der Affäre gezogen und
natürlich auch zurecht auf das
spitzenkandidatenmodell der
parteienbezogene hätte sicherlich einen
Fehler gemacht auch mit Blick auf seine
eigene Partei wenn ich hier eine
Vorfestlegung vorgenommen hätte er hat
ja selbst in vergangener Zeit dafür
geworben auf der anderen Seite schon
seine Begrüßung liebe Ursula und immer
dieses Hin und Her auch in dieser
Pressekonferenz macht natürlich deutlich
dass man sehr gut zusammenarbeitet und
eine amtierende Bundesregierung auch
wenn frau von der Leyen wieder dieser
einen Partei nach den beiden anderen
Koalitionsparteien angehört wäre
natürlich nicht klug beraten Sie in
Frage zu stellen aber er war sicherlich
heute nicht willens aus guten Gründen er
hätte sie im Zweifelsfalle auch eher mit
Blick auf die innenpolitischen
Implikation und die parteipolitischen
auch im Europaparlament
beschädigt weil es dann gleich heißen
hätte top down sozusagen der
Bundeskanzler er will uns hier die
Richtung beweisen dass es unsere Frage
so viel dazu das andere was Sie
ansprechen natürlich völlig Recht
e-fuels und anderes mehr wird dann sehr
relativ vor dem Hintergrund dessen was
den ersten Teil von beiderlei
Ausführungen natürlich eingenommen hat
nach wie vor der Konflikt der Krieg das
war der Einstieg das war sozusagen auch
die Fallhöhe vor der auch diese
Veranstaltung hier stattfindet und die
Relevanz der strittigen Themen die ist
ja nicht wenige gibt auch für den
Hintergrund der jetzt sich
finalisierenden Haushaltsberatung oder
fest Vorlesung
Festlegungen für den Bundeshaushalt
nächsten Jahres aber noch ist man
sozusagen in diesem krisenmodus und der
Kanzler weiß darauf hin und die Umfragen
sprechen auch dafür dass die
Bundesregierung zunächst sich darauf
beziehen kann dass die Bevölkerung
zufrieden ist mit diesem
Krisenmanagement außergewöhnliche Zeiten
nicht sozusagen von mit dem was im
Koalitionsvertrag vor über einem Jahr
als wirklich wegweisend angesehen wurde
hat ja die Relevanz wie das was man
sozusagen hier geopolitisch militärisch
Zeitenwende leisten musste aber jetzt
nimmt man natürlich auch zur Kenntnis
nicht nur in den USA auch in Europa und
auch hier natürlich Meseberg dass die
Innenpolitik die Wirtschaft die Folgen
die Agenda des Koalitionsvertrags
zunehmen doch wieder ins Bewusstsein
rückt und so arbeitet man sich vor eine
wunschkoalition war das für alle drei
Parteien nie das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen die FDP hat sich sehr schwer
getan sie hat ja lange noch darauf
gehofft mit der Union sozusagen aber
vielleicht ein Stück weit Richtung
Jamaika zu gehen und das ist zwischen
gelb und grün nie wirklich harmonisch
werden würde das wusste man damals schon
und das wird natürlich jetzt immer
deutlicher in diesen Sachfragen die vor
diesen ganzen Hintergründen verhandelt
werden gibt es einige die sozusagen
einander Ding wir haben sehr viel Geld
in die Hand genommen Stichwort
Sondervermögen für Anstrengungen um uns
sozusagen und die Bundeswehr auch der
einzige Minister der wirklich auch
sofort in den Beliebtheitswerten auch
sehr schnell nach vorne gekommen ist
Herr Pistorius relativ neu im Amt bei
den anderen muss man ein bisschen
Abstriche machen sowohl beim Kanzler
auch als bei seiner Partei die sehr weit
sozusagen unterhalb der Kante kämpft
aber bei diesen Projekten um die es
jetzt auch geht und die in Ukraine zum
Beispiel mit reinspielen ist die Frage
wie wir mit Flüchtlingen umgehen
das ist so ein Moment wo man sich und
sich viele in der Öffentlichkeit etwas
mehr Führung durch Herrn Scholz erwarten
es gab ganz konkrete Forderungen dass
wenn es zu einem flüchtlingsgipfel kommt
der eben nicht nur von seiner
Innenministerin abgehalten wird sondern
von ihm selbst also warum führt Scholz
wenn ich das jetzt mal so ausdrücken
darf so dezent
er nimmt ein Stück weit Anleihe an dem
Stil seiner Vorgängerin imitiert es hier
ein Stück weit auf der anderen Seite
dürfen wir nicht vergessen es ist nicht
noch nicht lange her da hatte die
Richtlinienkompetenz überraschenderweise
sozusagen gezogen die Karte bei der
Verlängerung eigentlich eher eine
technische Frage ich würde sagen
marginal aber sie war eher technischer
Natur da hat der Führung gezeigt
ansonsten ist es natürlich auch sein
Politikstil noch mal in ein Laie an
Merkel durchaus auch populär zu
moderieren wir haben eingangs gesagt und
das weiß er natürlich das hier drei
Partner miteinander arbeiten müssen und
das natürlich nach einem Jahr Krieg und
dann noch verschärften finanzpolitischen
Spielräumen ja immer immer enger werden
sozusagen eine Koalition die eben eher
auf Konflikt den auf Konsens angelegt
ist und der auf der anderen Seite dieses
Prinzip das macht Wortes auch nicht
allzu oft bedienen darf das wäre auch
nicht das Selbstverständnis sozusagen
dieser dieser
Ampelkoalition das heißt er versucht
natürlich im Hintergrund davon können
wir ausgehen natürlich seine
Vorstellungen auch durchzusetzen
Stichwort Flüchtlingspolitik diese
humanitären Fragen aber natürlich auch
die die ganzen damit verbundenen Fragen
der Sozialleistungen und anderes mehr da
hat er natürlich ein Gefühl dafür dass
er diese Dinge nicht allzu sehr treiben
lassen darf die Beschwerden der
Landkreise des Städte und Gemeindebundes
anderes mehr damit will ich sagen er
wird sicherlich in einigen Wochen dann
wenn er sich dazu genötigt fühlt dann
auch einladen ins Kanzleramt er versucht
eben solange erkannt Stichwort Väter
Innenministerin hier natürlich hier das
ist Kompetenz und sich daraus zu halten
dass er vor die Welle kommt dann wenn
ich es recht gelesen habe hat die Union
jetzt sozusagen einen eigenen
flüchtlingsgipfel mit den Kommunen
aufgerufen für den 30 März also das ist
so ein bisschen noch einmal ein Finger
zeig Olaf tu was gleichzeitig wir haben
es angesprochen und vielleicht das zu
einer schlusseinschätzung Professor
Volker Kronenberg es ist sie haben das
festgestellt keine einfache Koalition
auch wenn man sozusagen am schönen
ovalen Tisch mit wunderbaren Bildern
gestartet ist und wenn man auch in einer
Atmosphäre das war durchaus zu spüren
eines gegenseitigen Respekts und der
Sympathie angetreten ist aber man hat
doch den Eindruck da ist jetzt viel
schon abgerutscht ich will jetzt nicht
von Sollbruchstellen reden aber gewisse
Risse sind offenbar da können die so
stark werden dass hier was bricht oder
ist das sozusagen die normale
arbeitsreibung
ich würde fest davon ausgehen dass diese
Koalition nicht bricht es sind
außergewöhnliche Zeiten nach wie vor man
hat gemeinsam diese schwierige Koalition
dieser Ausnahmen Monate Krieg
hinbekommen man hat Sondervermögen man
hat natürlich ja auch parteipolitische
Interessen zurückgestellt das hat die
FDP getan Schulden aufgenommen das haben
die Grünen getanlaufzeit Verlängerung
AKW dann auch mit Waffenexporten andere
mehr also hier ist natürlich wahnsinnig
viel auch geschehen jenseits der Partei
so aber es finden noch Wahlen statt und
man nimmt natürlich zu Kenntnis und das
machen die Partner durchaus
unterschiedlich das hier unterschiedlich
natürlich auch die das Wahlverhalten
außer die FDP steht und unter Druck und
sie wird dann am Ende nicht nur daran
gemessen ob der Finanzminister diese
Sondervermögen ermöglicht hat sondern
und da sind wir wieder bei den
Haushaltsberatungen und bei den
geringeren finanzpolitischen Spielraum
und all den ich jetzt knirscht ob er
dafür auch einen steht was immer auch
liberale DNA war nämlich
Haushaltsdisziplin das Einhalten der
Schuldengrenze und die Grünen mit dem
Klima und den den der Frage ifür sind
und anderem mehr oder eben
Kindergrundsicherung da kommt die ganze
Palette der Themen jetzt aber brechen
wird nichts denn nach wie vor
außergewöhnliche Zeiten alle sind sich
dessen bewusst und Konflikte vor allem
die hat es in jeder Koalition in den
letzten Perioden immer gegeben und es
geht Professor Volker Kronenberg
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung
genügend Daten in diesem Wahljahr 2023
wupperparteien nervös werden können
eines war Berlin da haben wir schon
gesehen der CDU dann kommen Bremen und
Hessen und Bayern im Herbst also
Gelegenheit genug weiter mit ihnen zu
sprechen danke für Ihre Einschätzung
heute hier am Sonntagabend bei Phoenix
meine Damen und Herren vielen Dank dass
Sie mit uns waren dass sie sozusagen für
Phoenix vor Ort ihre Aufmerksamkeit mit
uns geteilt haben was Sie von uns
üblicherweise an einem Sonntag erwarten
können ist ein sehr dezidiertes Programm
wo wir auch einmal zeitgeschichtliche
Fragen aufnehmen wir tun das auch gerne
hin und wieder in sehr sehr etablierten
Dokumentation rein da gibt es eine die
heißt die Welt der Antike da geht es
nicht nur um die Eisenzeit da geht es
auch um Alexander den Großen all das
wollen wir Ihnen bringen also sozusagen
Persönlichkeiten die das gestern
bestimmt haben ich wünsche Ihnen wie
immer gute Information dafür nichts
[Musik]